chrissy teigen speaks out after she says
a paparazzo directed racist questions at
her and John Legend when they arrived in
New York the model took to social media
Thursday calling out the path in a
series of tweets that read quote
paparazzi at JFK just asked me if we
evolved from monkeys why is John Legend
still around adding quote also jon is
right next to me the balls I just
started to fall in love with how
engaging and witty and and funny she is
despite the airport drama the couple
steps out for a relaxing date night in
chic ensembles to see the Broadway debut
of August Wilson's play jitney how do
you find time for date night oh we find
tired yeah we had a great vacation over
the holiday and then we make time to a
date night movie night cooking at home
night we we do all sorts of things but
Chrissy canceled her plans to go to
Sundance with her husband on Friday to
attend the women's march on washington
DC the next day tweeting feeling
compelled to support my fellow women
you